hey guys I'm Kyle Warbeck and New York
Comic Con just released a new teaser
trailer for iron fist which is the
newest Marvel Netflix hero series and
I'm telling you this trailer freaking
hyped me up for this show so let's talk
about who this iron fist guy is and
digging to what we're really seeing in
this trailer because there are some
really cool miscible details in this
teaser and I also want to talk about how
this is all going to connect the shows
like daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage
and the upcoming defenders series so
let's just get into this because of who
you are there will always be forces
gathering against you disguised as a
friend slipping past you as a stranger
they are everywhere so this person we're
seeing here is our friend Danny Rand
played by Finn Jones aka sir Loras
Tyrell and Game of Thrones now there's
already a couple things to point out in
this first section but it helps to know
more about the iron fist origin story
from the comics because this guy is way
different from any of the other Netflix
shows that we've seen so far so who is
iron fist Danny Rand is the son of
Wendell Rand the wealthy head of Rand
industries / the rand corporation you
may have seen this company before
actually when their truck kind of
spilled chemicals on our friend Matt
Murdock in the first episode of
daredevil so when Danny was a boy
Wendell took him on an expedition in the
mountains of Tibet along with his wife
Heather and his longtime business
partner Harold Meacham this expeditions
purpose was to find the hidden city of
Kunlun which is one of the seven capital
cities of heaven these are mystical
cities from another dimension that are
spread across the earth and every 88
years they have a tournament with a
champion from each of these cities and
guess who is the champion of Kunlun our
boy iron fist which is actually a title
that many fighters over the ages have
carried now Danny's father Wendel has
kind of a long history with come on the
previous iron fist was his mentor but
I'm not gonna get too much into that the
point is there's a portal to the city in
the mountains that only opens every ten
years and Wendel was trying to return to
it but his pal Meacham here hold a total
scar from Lion King pushing Wendel off a
cliff and then trying to make a move on
his wife dick move Meacham Meacham
hardly know him crickets crickets
crickets as for Danny he eventually gets
picked up by the people of c'mon and
becomes the iron fist after training
under Lee Kong the Thunderer Li kung is
the weapons in martial arts master of
Kunlun and I'm pretty sure it's his
voice that we're hearing in this trailer
because of who you are there will always
be forces gathering against you now I
don't really know how much the iron fist
show will really get into this whole
cities of heaven thing it kind of seems
like it's more centered on what happens
when Danny Rand returns to New York to
avenge his father against this guy
Harold Meacham who we see menacingly
facing away from us here like the Mad
Men logo let's back up a couple shots
here these two people are Ward and joy
meet Jim in the comics Ward is Harold's
brother and joy is Harold's daughter but
the show is changing it so they're both
Harold's children we hear Lee Kong's
voice warned us that their enemies
disguised as a friend and my guess is
that they aren't to have you with
Danny's sudden return to take over the
company and plot to attack their dad but
I'll talk about why the Meacham's look
the way they do a little later but
before I move on we get a quick look at
Colleen wing here now she's a key ally
of iron fist in the comics along with
Luke Cage and misty Knight based on the
easter-egg from the final episode of
Luke Cage it looks like she's gonna be
introduced as a martial arts teacher
living in New York and Colleen appears
to have the same awesome white-handled
samurai sword that she does in the
comics that moment in Luke Cage also
kind of suggests that Claire temple's
gonna show up in one of Colleen's
classes also according to the Casa list
Gery hogarth will show up at some point
during iron fist so clearly all the
parts of this defenders universe are
just collapsing in on each other anyways
moving on
if you choose to continue as you are
know that you risk everything it's time
so check out this shot of the bubbles
another shot later in the trailer shows
us more of what's going on here but for
now it's interesting to know how the
editing syncs up perfectly with Li Kong
saying they are everywhere we see these
bubbles being too numerous to count and
completely surrounding us much like
Danny's enemies so I see what they did
there we also get a quick shot of Madame
Gao from daredevil which is awesome she
was the head of the Chinese crime
syndicate in Hell's Kitchen selling a
form of heroin she called steel serpent
which by the way was actually a
reference to a character in the Iron
Fist comics steel serpent aka Davos was
leaked Hong's son and Danny rands rival
he was super envious that Danny became
the iron fist and he later joins forces
with the Meacham's to kill iron fist
now I'm not sure if he's gonna show up
in the iron fist show we already know
Louis tan is playing another villain
Shao Qiang who serves a demon named chi
lin and hunts down all the iron fists
but the fact that Madame Gao is showing
up now in this show may be giving us
hints about her real identity
Marvel's been hinting that Madame Gao is
really crane mother crane mother is the
leader of Kunze which is another
mystical City are you writing these down
but the big thing with her is that she
has a long vendetta against the iron
fist name and wants it destroyed so it
makes sense if she's showing up to just
kick Danny rands ass also you can barely
make out Danny Rand in this wide shot of
the crowded New York Street but that's
him right there gazing up and off this
is actually part of another clip that
was played at New York Comic Con showing
Danny coming back to New York City all
barefoot and drifter II and unless you
live in New York you might have thought
this building looks kind of like CGI
kind of like how they put the Avengers
power over the real-life Conde Nast
building but this is a real Building
seven Bryant Park and my guess is that
this is gonna be the headquarters of
rent industries so after this we see
Danny meditating and as he does so we
see a few shots flash across the screen
kind of showing him into different
stages so this first shot is him as a
boy and it looks like he's on the
private jet here when his mother's hand
is
his face but check out that cut on his
forehead I'm wondering if this quick
shot is actually in the middle of the
plane crash and Danny you know like
sustained this injury during the
turbulence or something and if you pause
fast enough you can see Danny meditating
in robes with peaceful-looking mountains
in the background I'm pretty sure this
is taking place in con 1 and if you
pause it even faster look it's a deer on
greyjoy anyways moving on a child
touched by fire destined to be a pretty
storia so here we see young Danny red
still strapped into his airplane seat in
the mountains probably ejected from the
fuselage of the crashed airplane that
would make the origin story a little
different from the comics this implies
that Herald Meechum could have like
caused the plane crash to happen in the
Himalayas which would be a hell of an
epic visual to begin Danny rants origins
story after that we get some badass
shots of Danny rent and some kind of
self constructed costume kind of like
the black ninja costume Matt Murdock
wore before he officially became
daredevil in season 1 and I'll be honest
I kind of love it how much more on the
side of these street-level Marvel
Netflix heroes wearing more like
realistic practical costumes even though
daredevil seems to be kind of moving
away from that now so the shots don't
last long but it looks kind of like
Danny's Iron Fist power is causing the
light bulbs overhead to explode and
shatter and I love how that connects
visually to the titles that flash like
camera flashes in between these images
syncing with the cool industrial rock
music the final defender arrives it kind
of sounds like when like a WWE wrestler
enters the arena like it just like hyped
you up so much
defenders okay so I should point out
that Marvel Studios is really only using
the defenders in name only because in
the Marvel Comics the defenders is
actually a very different team with
Doctor Strange and Hulk and Silver
Surfer and Namor their mission being to
defend Earth from more supernatural
interdimensional threats and the
Avengers could really handle meanwhile
the version of the defenders will see on
Netflix will probably be more like
Heroes for Hire from the comics which is
more like grounded in New York without a
lot of the big picture existential
crises going on so we also see more of
the bubble scene from before and now we
know it's taking place on a city street
with people celebrating and waving wands
but I'm still not really sure what's
going on here why is Danny wearing a
mask what are these people celebrating I
think like Chinese New Year I don't
really know what that looks like this
could just be me but this shot feels
like the opening scene of Spectre and
just like bond Danny could be using the
chaos of a street party to approach a
target the best place to hide is it
plain sight oh no I'm doing that these
two characters here look like they've
can be from Kunlun and judging from the
low angle we could be seeing them from
Danny's point of view after the crash
and these are like the people saving him
and before I move on over all this we
hear Lee Kong say a child touched by
fire destined to be a greatest warrior
that's actually referring to another
part of Iron Fist backstory which I'll
explain right after we take a look at
this next section
you are lovely things with them okay so
this shot of Danny's glowing fist is one
of the coolest shots from the trailer
this is all iron fists power works he
powers off by summoning his Chi and then
just goes the town channeling it through
his body to give his hits like
superhuman impact in this show it seems
like how powerful iron fist is they're
gonna kind of limit it to something on
the level with the other street-level
Marvel heroes and the comics often
showed his fists being on fire but this
visual effect makes the power look like
it's coming from within him like you can
see his veins and his tendons which is
kind of Awesome and he medically
accurate we also hear Lee Kong describe
him has you all of the big things weapon
so how exactly did iron fist get this
power I mean he trained it became a
fighting badass and Kunlun but he wasn't
like a superhero yet so in order to gain
the title of iron fist he had to fight a
dragon called Shula with the undying
Danny slew the dragon the only fighter
to ever do that by the way and then he
pressed his chest against the symbol on
the Dragons belly which transferred the
Dragons power to him and left him with
this mark so that's basically how he has
the power to jump punch through this
metal vault door we actually see the
reverse shot of this vault door being
blown off later in the trailer now we
also see some shots what looks like
another brutal hallway fight sequence
which has kind of become a rite of
passage for these Marvel Netflix shows
we get to see more of iron fists fight
choreography which seems more based in
smoother martial arts like kung foo then
the Messier more frantic fighting of
daredevil and Luke Cage we know that one
Iron Fist episode will be directed by
Kevin and that's his last name
I'm not even gonna try to pronounce it
but this guy directed some of the best
fight scenes and agents of shield he's a
big lover of martial arts and that could
really set Iron Fist apart from the
other shows in its universe anyways
moving on try all other thoughts
your mind except this so there's a lot
of action here but let's dig in and look
a little more closely at some of these
quick shots this first location looks a
lot like where we saw Harold Meacham
sitting before with the same swanky
furniture and possible to rarey him off
to the side this could be setting up a
storyline from the comics but it's a
spoiler so click - this time if you
don't want to know it so in the comics
when Danny Rand returns to New York he
seeks revenge against Meacham for the
death of his parents as you should and
he comes one stroke away from killing me
Chum but ultimately his conscious wins
him over and he decides not to but then
a mystery ninja appears and kills
Meacham anyway leaving the other mediums
to blame Iron Fist for his death despite
what Danny decided this look of iron
fist in black assassin clothes fighting
what looks like a corporate bodyguard in
the same place we see Meacham earlier in
the trailer all seems like it could be
part of the same revenge storyline and
that shot of Ward and joy from earlier
they're both wearing black here like
they're dressed for their father's
funeral anyways welcome back people who
didn't want to see the spoilers let's
check out these next shots we see
Colleen wing in a cage match fighting
ring and check out that white outfit
that looks a lot like the white jumpsuit
that Colleen wing wears in the comics
and I also love the idea that this could
be how were introduced the Colleen wing
taking down these huge brutes which
would actually be very similar to the
first time we see Wolverine in a movie
now before I move on take a look at this
quick shot here my first thought was
that this is Colleen in a new black
outfit attacking Danny in the same
location where he was fighting earlier
in the trailer my guess is Mitra martial
arts classes flyer and Luke Cage and
hired her for extra protection from
Danny leading them into the steamy
daredevil lecture a style fight but some
people online are saying this can be a
totally different character from iron
fist
the Bride of nine spiders which is the
craziest name just like how iron fist is
the champion of con Munn the bride of
nine spiders is the champion of another
legendary city the kingdom of spiders
who would want to live there though even
though these black clothes are a bit
similar to that character in the comics
I still think this looks more like
Colleen wing maybe your costume is just
like a no Maj to that character or
something but let's move on to the final
shot of this trailer here
this is my purpose so here we get the
shot of iron fists iconic chest tattoo
this is the marquee got from the dragon
Shu Lao and he becomes his character's
sigil I love the way the show uses it in
the title as the oh and the word iron
ended the smoke behind it and remember
guys you aren't a true Iron Fist fan
until you actually get this tattoo on
your chest I have it as a [ __ ] stamp
which Eric told me isn't cool I'm sorry
Eric that's what happens when you touch
your butt to a dead dragon and also take
note of what Danny brand says here this
is my purpose this is what Netflix chose
to end the trailer on so what is he
referring to
I predict that this revenge story line
against Meechum will be just one part of
the season kind of like how there was
two halves to Luke Cage and his bigger
threat will be another big conflict from
the iron fist comics the hand which is
the Ancient Order of evil ninjas trying
to destroy civilization the hand was
already well established in Marvel's
Netflix universe and daredevil second
season and if you remember Matt Murdock
was kinda on the fence about whether he
even wanted to fight this ancient war
his attention was torn between that and
his law firm and dealing with Frank
castle on the blacksmith and Luke Cage
didn't bring up the hand at all so iron
fist is probably gonna have to pick up
where daredevil left off on the hand
since in the comics iron fist in the
hand or kind of natural enemies now I
don't expect iron fisted totally do away
with the hand as a threat to this
universe I think this conflict might
even set up a showdown that we'll see in
the defenders show hopefully we'll get a
hint about who the big bad is that
Sigourney Weaver's gonna be playing now
I am super freaking excited that we're
getting an iron fist show reading the
comics I never even imagined we were
gonna see him on the screen so I'm
really looking forward to talking about
it more and one of the big reasons new
rockstars is even able to make videos
about iron fist is our sponsor loot
crate loot crate is a monthly
subscription box service that hooks you
up with a bunch of cool gear from all
the nerdy stuff that we cover on this
channel including Marvel Comics you can
sign up right now by going to loot crate
calm slash rockstars each month has a
theme and the theme for the box that
just came in here is speed so let's take
a look
well so next month's theme is gonna be
horror and you could get that by signing
up by the 19th of the month by 9 p.m.
Pacific it's less than 20 bucks a month
and if you use our promo code rockstars
you get 10% off and we at new rock stars
are doing a bonus giveaway where you'll
have a chance to win the box that I just
opened just sign up for loot crate right
now at Luke Raycom slash rock stars and
tweeted us to let us know what you're
most excited about for Iron Fist ok
that's it if you liked this video please
hit like and subscribe to new rockstars
and share this video with your friends
you can also contribute to us on patreon
a huge thank you to all of our current
patrons you guys are the best we've been
able to get videos out so much faster
and all the thanks to you guys thank you
so much you can also hit me up on
Twitter with any thoughts or questions
or mean or gifs and you can hit up new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for info on when our videos are gonna be
coming out so thanks for watching I'm
just gonna be sitting right here waiting
for iearnt this to come out so I'll be
here
[Music]
[Music]
you